[Musique]
mais il faut être un homme heureux
simca qui fonctionne bien herbert
léonard va venir nous rejoindre alors
que nous avons c'est vrai que c'est pas
le cas tous les jours fait venir un
piano sur le studio 12 de la sfp pour
vous permettre de vous retrouver un tout
petit peu peut-être comme vous avez
l'habitude de travailler je sais pas
comment ça se passe quand vous composez
quand vous étudiez des chansons vous
êtes comme ça un peu comme à la maison
généralement est d'abord d'abord nous on
travaille de la façon suivante on attend
que l'huile et des idées mélodiques qui
lui à nous les jouets et puis on les des
chiffres après oui et non mais c'est
vrai que là c'est un mauvais exemple
parce que c'est une des très rares
chansons que julien n'a pas composé oui
mais on a quand même dix ans de
collaboration très intense derrière nous
et c'est un pianiste a d'ailleurs de
très grand talent il va douiller
renversant tout à fait extraordinaire
renversement comme en août une demande
lui de chantier voila tu vas nous faire
une petite compensation alors à temps
imaginé messieurs un peu d'ordre mais
c'est une chanson imaginé une chanson
pour julien lepers
imaginons que nous soyons pour le
plaisir c'était quoi en 1981 c'est moi
qui joue mais ces berbères qui chante
c'est sortir en quatre ans est sorti en
80 sorties
tu vois déjà l'intro et les bains à
bastia je suis revenue à la chanson sa
cause de cet antre ont le cancer grâce à
je dirais grâce au paraphe
tu vois il chante chante en attend
un mets haut
la plaisanterie sans regarder
une fille dans la rue
essai
[Musique]
la tierce 101 à tort
mais pour le plaisir
eto'o
en passant
simplement
les souriait
et
deux mois
prendre le temps
le temps
en temps de paix
comme un enfant
et c'est loupé
ou pour le plaisir
[Musique]
dans le dans le domaine des clins d'oeil
je crois me souvenir d'une chanson qui
s'appelait isabelle ou halo isabelle il
y avait un répondeur téléphonique il me
semble bien que la voix c'était la
tienne
oui c'est vrai ça c'est dur il n'aime
pas qu'on aime qu'on parle de cette
chanson parce que c'est une histoire de
cocu et dans la chanson c'était lui le
quotidien
allô allô isabelle mais pourquoi m'as tu
quittais dans les chansons plus connues
il y en a eu d'autres qui ont fait de
gros succès vous avez mérité la nuit
à
le
chic nathalie c'était super hein
kate nathalie minutes
rentre chez toi
e
di natali
pabr assoit encore une fois
ben
besson
minable
[Applaudissements]
on attend qu'il ait pas changer ça
balade
[Musique]
il faut le forcer un petit gens c'est ça
les timides en fait il faut les violer
un petit je le fais exprès pour qui
chantent
en 2000 vous êtes rencontrés comment on
s'est rencontrés par la clautre en soit
enfin quelques uns directement c'est
claude françois qui m'a présenté un jour
une grande grande hauteur qui s'appelle
ville buggy tu connais bien sûr qu'il ya
vincent avec l'aude avec michel sardou
notamment hugues aufray johnny et
avec lui on a travaillé ensemble quelque
temps je lui montrais mes petites
chansons et elle m'a dit mais il ya un
artiste qui chanterai toutes les
chansons très bien c'est herbert léonard
ce que tu connais je connaissais de nom
mais je connaissais pas personnellement
elle me dit on va organiser un rendez
vous et je vais te le présenter on verra
si ça marche
à ce moment-là herbert avait quasiment
quitter le métier moi ça faisait
pratique presque dix ans que je ne
chantais plus oui en fait tu es revenu
avec pour le plaisir je connais non
seulement un retour mais un retour en
force des acheteurs venus pour deux
raisons d'abord parce tevlin buggy qui
me le demander c'est s était resté
unamimes malgré les dix ans d'absence et
ensuite parce que ses chansons étaient
vraiment extraordinaire quoi il est venu
avec un wagon de chansons d'un coup et
ça nous a donné le matériel pour faire
une demi douzaine d'albums ensemble des
voix alors j'ai dit oui c'est vincent
une petite dernière pour la route
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te fasse
que ce qui te plaît rêvassant c'est eux
qui décident
laissez nous rêver ah oui laissez nous
rêver très bien excellent laissez nous
rêver 8
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
fais comme tu veux
des compressions et bâle
ensuite le titre avis le titre arrive
[Musique]
ce
à
et
les cadeaux
7 heures
[Musique]
c'est fini que l'on n'aura jamais
deux artistes mes deux amis julien
lepers les repères
attention ces voitures ou bien sur un
plateau comme le nôtre pour servais et
je veux dire on se voit pas
[Musique]